hi guys hi everyone thank you so much
for having me here
it's a pleasure thank you for joining us
and sorry for the you know collapse of
the
internet your talk
um
i i wouldn't want to be a stream yard
engineer right now um i would have been
probably would have aged 10 years in one
day
but it's great you've made it and so um
i'll just introduce abu bakar to
everyone so
um abu bakar is the ceo of gradios so
this um kind of cool applications that
mervei just showed us uh the kind of
brainchild of abu bakar and his
and in his role as the ceo of radio he
works on making machine learning models
easier to demo debug and deploy
and today he'll talk to us about
building machine learning applications
fast
so i'll share the video and then we'll
do a q a afterwards
hello everyone my name is abu bakker i'm
one of the founders and ceo of gradio
and i'll be talking about how to build
machine learning applications fast
before i get started
a decade ago mark and rayson famously
said that software and software
applications were eating the world
fast forward to 2021 and it seems like
machine learning applications are eating
the world this is a screen grab of
hugging face spaces and you see all of
these different machine learning
applications and demos that were created
and deployed on spaces just over the
course of five days
there are machine learning applications
that span things like education machine
learning applications for entertainment
for productivity art being able to find
things more easily and even
accessibility so let's take a look at
just a couple of these applications
so for art
this
demo this space was recently built by
asan khalid and what it does it takes it
as input a photo a realistic image and
it converts it to a
uh
another image that that is essentially
the same image but it's like a
hand-drawn version of it it's called
animegan um and it basically does
automated rotoscoping um this is really
cool because something like this takes a
lot of time for people to do manually
and now you have the ability for
ordinary people taking their own photos
their own profile pictures and creating
art from the from those photos and from
those pictures
uh so people you know we once we built
and released this demo we saw thousands
of people across the world really using
it on pictures of themselves pictures of
their babies of their pets
and even ordinary objects
that's pretty cool machine learning here
has the potential to bring uh artistic
you know ability and talent to anyone
who has a particular vision of a type of
art that they want to be able to create
let's look at another application this
one has elements of productivity into it
so here there's a there's a space that
was built by ben decoder and what it
does it uses machine learning models to
take a news article so you just put in
the url of a news article it scrapes the
content and it then summarizes it for
you it gives you a one paragraph summary
so for example in this case you have uh
you have you know an article about ai
powered hiring and kind of a summary of
the bias that might happen as a result
that's quite interesting
and this is really powerful because
again it makes it a lot easier to con to
consume content that might be you know
very long uh you you have articles you
have you know pages books whatever you
want to read you can get summaries of it
first and then if you're interested you
can kind of dive more deeply it makes it
possible to consume a wider array of
content
so the reason i bring all this up is
because we're at a very interesting
point in the usage of machine learning
early on it was you know academics and
hackers that were using machine learning
uh
and you know over time it became you
know machine learning engineers software
engineers people with some sort of
dedicated expertise that were using
machine learning oftentimes in a
business context
and now what you have is you have anyone
who can use a gui or an or a browser can
now actually take advantage of machine
learning again to create art or to learn
things or to build productivity tools or
use these different models that have
been created
that's it's super powerful especially if
you compare it you know in many ways it
it is parallel to the development of
personal computing in the early days of
personal computing you had really only
maybe hackers that were you know
very kind of on the on the cutting edge
of technology that were using computers
over time became more dedicated
engineers especially in business context
that were using it
and you know ever since the introduction
of the original you know maybe perhaps
apple
uh computer with the gui
kind of a mass audience can take
advantage of personal computing and the
mass audience certainly has taken
advantage of personal computing and you
know the the
developments and the possibilities have
been you know i think
really unforeseen by anyone at that time
and we're at a similar stage with
machine learning and you know as kind of
you can tell here we went a long way
from those early stages of uh
of those guise and i think the same is
probably going to happen with machine
learning as well we're pretty much at
very much at the early days of this
of this widespread adoption
so with that being said i mean given how
much promise machine learning
applications have
uh how do we actually build them how do
we actually build them
well it's not so bad just take your
machine learning model that you've
trained in python in tensorflow or
pytorch or jacks or maybe with some a
library on top like hugging face
you go from there then you
build a web application on top of that
you containerize it with docker you find
a hosting solution like aws
and then of course you want to build an
interactive user interface so a lot of
different people can can use it so you
learn some web scripting you put
together a little gui and then people
are using it people are submitting data
you might want to store that you can see
how the model is doing and improve it so
you build a mysql database
so all of that is needed just to build a
machine learning application
or at least it used to be now we have
much better solutions particularly if
you want to build machine learning
applications fast we at gradio have
abstracted away a lot of these different
steps deploying your model building a
gui throwing incoming samples all of
that can be done with with gradio and
the beauty of it is it's all done in
python which is a language we machine
learning engineers
use on love
so how does this actually look well let
me show you a practical example and i
won't go too much into like a tutorial
around gradio there's lots of resources
online if you're interested in that but
i just want to give you kind of a taste
of it so you go ahead and you import
gradio because radio is a python package
then you instantiate a gradio.interface
class so this is this interface class is
the core class in gradio and it takes in
three arguments the first argument is
the function the python function
which is usually like a wrapper on the
model that you want to deploy
and then the next two parameters are
what kind of input and output you want
so in this case i want a drag and drop
image interface that feeds into my skin
image classifier the classifier returns
a dictionary of of confidences of
predictions and that gets outputted as a
label so let's see what this looks like
in practice but before i show you what
it looks like i do want to mention that
when you launch the you can write all of
this code to create this interface and
to launch it and you can run this from
any environment that you can run python
on so you could run this from a python
terminal for sure you could run this
from a jupyter notebook jupyter lab
or a collab environment even kaggle or
ruplet anywhere you can run python you
can run this which is which is very
powerful and what you'll see is it'll go
ahead and create an interface like this
and this interface here for example you
can drop in an image here and you can
see the prediction you can even edit it
and you'll notice this edit button over
here this allows you to adjust things
like the brightness or the crop and you
can see how the predictions change in
real time so
this three lines of code produces this
interface here
of course you can modify things we don't
just support images or text we support
things like video audio input we support
as output html json
files all sorts of different things so
here's
another interface that you could create
around video gpt so this is a model that
you put in a video and it tries to
predict the next frame of the video so
again super easy to wrap a an interface
around that
if you ever want to build a more complex
model that takes in multiple inputs or
multiple outputs that's also super easy
just pass in a list of those inputs or
list of those outputs and again same
thing just launch it and it creates this
now you may be wondering where this
application is running and by default it
runs locally so it runs in your local
host
and you can kind of you know run do
everything locally and you can test it
and your data doesn't go anywhere
but in many settings you actually want
to be able to share your model with
somebody else and so by just adding one
parameter here share equals true
what this does is this creates a public
url you can see this here
95338.radio.app here it creates a
temporary public url which allows anyone
to actually try your web application no
deployment you don't have to worry about
deployment or dependencies or anything
like that
you can just pass this link around like
a google doc link and then someone else
will be able to try out your model this
means you can take that model that
you've built and you can share it with
your users with your collaborators with
your boss with your teammates with your
parents anyone who you want to be able
to try out the model and what they can
do is they can you know drag and drop in
their own images and see what the
prediction is like or if they're on
their phone the ui automatically adjusts
to be mobile responsive and instead of
dragging and dropping an image you
can actually pick one from your gallery
or to use use the phone camera to take
one as well and just in real time you
can see the prediction so this is really
powerful and of course this applies to
all the different kinds of ui components
that we have
so yeah so this lets anyone try out a
model immediately without having to have
worry about software dependencies
hardware dependencies because your model
continues to run locally so that the web
ui gets deployed but gradient handles
the message passing back and forth
meaning that the person on the other end
doesn't have to over any dependencies or
really even need any sort of technical
expertise they can just try out your
model
if they can open up a browser window
if you want more permanent hosting we
recommend trying out hugging face spaces
that's the preferred kind of deployment
solution hugging face has made it super
easy to deploy a machine learning model
and you can kind of see how that process
looks like in this gif
um i won't go into the details here but
you can there there's a great blog post
on the hugging face website on how to
deploy gradius spaces
and once your app is up on the hugging
face spaces a lot of cool things happen
first of all
now you can actually use that demo that
you've built or anybody else has built
and put up on spaces you can use it like
a function in your regular code
so that new summarization model i
mentioned earlier built by ben decoder i
i can load it as a gradient interface
here i'm loading it just by passing in
the spaces path to it
and
now i can then use it as a function i
can now summarize new links here i've
had it summarize a cnn article on covid
okay and of course you can do this with
text
in demos we can also do this with image
demos by passing in the url to an image
or the file path to an image or you can
do this with video or audio or even
multimodal by passing in multi
like different parameters corresponding
to the different inputs
if there's a space
up on hugging face spaces that you like
if there's a demo that you like but you
want to tweak it a little bit to suit
your use case you can do that easily so
for example here's a cool demo that
removes the background from an image
i like that but maybe i want to attach
it to my webcam instead of a drag and
drop image interface well i can just add
one parameter here that overrides the
input to be a webcam i launch it again
and now hey look at that now it's
connected to my webcam and i can now run
it run it with my webcam and confirm
that it works
okay you can also mix and match spaces
now this is pretty cool so that new
summarization model maybe i want to
connect it to a model that translates
from english to german and so i can put
them in series
and now voila i have a
a model that takes in a url
and converts it to a summary of that
news article in german
so you kind of see this here so it's
taken this alpha fold article and it's
summarized it and then converted it to
german so i can now put
demos
spaces in series or even in parallel to
compare different things and so you can
read more about that on the gradient
website
but the biggest thing of course why
build machine learning apps and why
deploy them on spaces the biggest thing
is it completely democratizes access to
machine learning
any
of the 4.7 billion people connected to
the internet that's a huge number can
now use your machine learning model
what bigger way can we actually
democratize the the potential of machine
learning than making our models our
applications accessible to the wider
world
all right with that if you'd like to
give gradio a spin
you can pip install it and then you can
run some sample code that we've provided
here
and you'll see that you'll be able to
spin up an interface in no time if you
want to see more guides like this then
visit our website www.gradio.app
and thank you very much my name is abu
bakr abid i'm on twitter as abid labs
a-b-i-d-l-a-b-s
if you'd like to reach me that's
probably the best way
or of course reach us through the
website the link that i just provided
great welcome back okay
really cool talk it's nice to to see
this like high level summary of of kind
of the motivation behind gradio and also
the
the cool like modalities and different
applications
thank you
i think you have to actually have lived
the pain of building your own
application to really appreciate how
amazing this is because for example i
think my very first ml model was like
wrapped in flask
um and i had no idea what like flask was
i didn't even know what like web
applications were and you know this is
kind of like not your domain really as
an engineer as i mean maybe it is but
like
you know you should really be focusing
on the ml part not the
not the front end and radio is i think
really awesome for doing that
exactly
exactly yeah now i've definitely lived
the pain a lot i think during my phd
actually several times i had to do this
and it's not it's
it's not just about
the fact that it's hard i think the fact
that it's hard that it's hard also
prevents
people from like making sure that their
machine learning applications work in
the real world as well if that makes
sense because people know that okay i
can publish a model it doesn't really
have to work as long as it hits certain
metrics
but i think
having this kind of making this the
normal workflow you've built a model
you're going to deploy it
i think make sure that you know a lot of
issues that we talk about with bias and
robustness actually get surfaced and
then hopefully solve as well
yeah exactly and i think one thing
that's really like exciting is that i
mean most of the time the machine
learning models that we build they serve
they should ideally serve humans in some
way yeah and
you know a lot of the time the the
person who's interacting with the model
um it really helps if you can if you can
do that right because you know just
showing like a table of light
performance you know exactly
stuff like this this doesn't really
excite anyone and especially when you
work in industry like
the the end users who are often domain
experts and so on they really appreciate
like being able to click buttons and
like say oh not just like does it work
but like i've i've experienced people
doing adversarial attacks online
absolutely
absolutely no i've seen that i've seen
that so often actually i remember
the first very first application upgrade
which is you know where we built it it
was for a
a model that looked at these like
ultrasound pictures of the heart and it
could detect different things like if
there is a pacemaker in the heart or
whatnot and i remember like we presented
it to this cardiologist and he was
skeptical like our numbers were very
good but he was skeptical
and then he like adversarially tested it
he like edited that pacemaker out of it
and then the prediction of the model
changed like from there's a pacemaker
that there's no pacemaker and when that
happened multiple times like the
cardiologist was actually convinced and
even us like the machine learning
engineers in the room we all breathe the
sigh of relief
because one thing to have like good
numbers but another thing like when it's
actually stress tested it works that's
actually a really good thing i think
that's kind of the other piece of it is
one
these guys these demos reveal if there's
issues of bias and robustness but then
also like if it's actually a good model
it helps build trust in the model which
is of course very important in these
kind of interdisciplinary machine
learning applications
awesome
so we've got a couple of questions uh
i'd like to maybe ask so one is here
so someone's asked
um graduate supports a lot of modalities
like text images and video what's the
next focus for the team so yeah i don't
know what's beyond the space of these
three but maybe you have some cool ideas
uh definitely yeah so in terms of
modalities there's a few modalities
we're looking at right now for example
3d images
a lot of fun work being done there
but
kind of just more broadly speaking uh
there's you know there's a lot of like
enhancements we're doing to the library
but and the next big thing we're looking
at is thinking about how to actually
scale up radio demos which are designed
mostly for like single sample inference
like you put in one sample you run it uh
two more
fully fledged applications where you can
take the same you know function whatever
model you have and then easily build a
gui around it that can actually handle
you know batching large volumes of data
of course this is obviously a very
important use case
um yeah in a lot of different settings
and so we want to
and like a lot of you know repeated work
happens in making these applications and
a lot of different contexts so we're
we're talking to folks right now on how
to handle like bigger volumes of data
what do those use cases look like
and um so if if you're if you work you
know if you want something like this
like what gradio does before you know
bigger volumes of data reach out to me
definitely would be happy to chat
everything but how to implement that
awesome that actually segues into like
another question which would be like if
you're operating in a in a say
enterprise context a lot of the time
there's questions of security so like
yeah
maybe i need to put like a password on
my application yeah you have any plans
to support these features or do maybe
you do already yeah yeah so we so we do
offer authentication so with one extra
parameter in the launch method auth
equals and then you can specify like
username password so you can definitely
do that
um
and people do that all the time uh i
think the the more the the very common
use case that we see is people want an
on-premise type solution or or uh
something that runs entirely on their
vpc so like the radio servers are not
included at all and for something like
that we offer something called radio
private which
is essentially kind of you think of an
on-premise version of gradio and we work
with you know enterprises different
companies to make that happen yeah cool
cool thanks there's another question we
have here um
so grady looks great for people who know
how to code do you have plans to make it
even simpler for people who don't
yeah
so that's a great question um so we we
actually so that is a really good
question i
at this point i think the general kind
of assumption that we have is that
people who are using radio right you
know do have some kind of familiarity
with uh basics of python and we just
want to make that a lot easier for
people to be able to build these
front-end you know applications you know
the idea is that you know python but you
might not necessarily know these
front-end applications uh you know
front-end languages web scripting and so
on um
as of now i think we'd have to think
pretty deeply about
what that kind of use case looks like
um that sounds interesting you know
making it completely kind of drag and
drop and all that that could be
interesting we don't currently have
plans but we can definitely think about
that more
yeah cool
yeah like i think the whole like no code
like um sort of like domain it's a kind
of a tricky one because
like on the one hand you want to empower
domain experts to
like actually say build their
applications but then if you think about
it like what does it mean to build an ml
application and then
you have this whole like like knowledge
that you sort of implicitly assume of
the end user like what is a model what
is the
prediction
and metrics or all this kind of stuff
exactly
and i think yeah it's not quite clear
like where the the level or the you know
the entry point is um yeah
absolutely exactly so we'd have to
definitely think about that a little bit
more but it's definitely intriguing yeah
cool there's maybe one last question
i've seen on the forums which is kind of
a bit related um so will gradio come out
as a friendly desktop interface in the
future
sometimes the model can't be used
publicly but it's instead used
internally in a company yeah uh
absolutely so that's where um i think
the radio private that i mentioned you
know briefly can be useful
uh i think web interfaces is fine as
long as it's running you know either
locally or on your internal network
which is what radio private uh aims to
do so if that sounds interesting or if
that doesn't cover kind of the secure
need or the internal lead out i'd be
happy to hear more but uh but yeah we
work with you know a bunch of companies
to actually do this internal use case
even like folks that are doing medical
you know very sensitive data and
everything just works you know
internally and everything is encrypted
so usually that that satisfies that
constraint but it's a it's a good
question i'd definitely love to hear
more uh from this particular user so
feel free to reach out to me
yeah cool awesome
well thank you
i think
well done right
last words
no thank you so much you know we we're
working on a lot of very exciting
integrations the hugging page
specifically i mean it's just such a
natural kind of integration there with
spaces and so on so i really appreciate
you guys you know inviting me over and
and uh good luck you know enjoy the rest
of the event to all the viewers thank
you bye-bye
all right thanks break up